it's 7 o'clock this is sky news
breakfast and here are our top stories
this morning facing the rest of her life
behind bars british socialite galen
maxwell is found guilty of helping
jeffrey epstein sexually abuse teenage
girls
others must be held accountable virginia
dufrese one of maxwell's accusers says
she now has faith others connected to
the crimes will face justice following
the verdict
meanwhile gulen maxwell's families say
they are very disappointed with the
verdict and have already started the
appeals process against the decision
and i'm in new york where lawyers for
guillerme maxwell's victims say some
justice has been served but more now
needs to be done told others responsible
for their role in jeffrey epstein's
criminal enterprise
setting up for a surge new nightingale
hubs are rolled out at eight locations
across england as the nhs prepares for a
wave of omicron hospital admissions
testing times a shortage of coveted test
kits across the country but the uk
health security agency promises eight
million more will be available before
the new year
the u.s calls on china to immediately
release employees of the pro-democracy
media outlet strand news after they were
arrested by hong kong authorities
baby benefits sky news speaks to the
companies helping staff start a family
through ivf
and the weather mild but windy with rain
in the south and showers in the far
north for a time
and that of course too we'll look at the
smallest papers with the journalists
alpha adam and thomas copeland
[Music]
hello there very good morning thanks for
joining us the 60 year old british
socialite delane maxwell is facing the
rest of her life behind bars after being
found guilty of recruiting underage
girls to be sexually abused by geoffrey
epstein maxwell who was described as
dangerous and epstein's partner in crime
by the prosecution during her three-week
trial was convicted on five of the six
counts she was charged with her accusers
including virginia dufrese say others
connected to the crimes must now be held
accountable following the verdict
meanwhile maxwell's families say they've
already started the appeal process
against the decision well a warning this
report from our u.s correspondent martha
kellner does contain some flash
photography
guillen maxwell was the socialite whose
manners and magnetism attracted princes
and presidents but it was those same
qualities she used to ensnare girls from
troubled backgrounds teenagers whom she
served up for abuse by jeffrey epstein
her siblings were in court as the
verdict was read out they know she'll
almost certainly spend the rest of her
life in prison so too do her lawyers
laura i wonder if you can reflect
on why you think
that this jury believed the
prosecution's case that glenn maxwell
was a sexual predator
it was the verdict her accusers say is
long overdue
among them sarah ransom who was in court
for some of the trial what was it that
gillane did
to
manipulate girls in order to serve them
up to jeffrey epstein what was her role
in the crime so guillen was the main
enforcer she was
you know even before i met elaine
jeffrey said you answer to guillen you
know
she is the lady of the house she is
um you just don't cross her she forced
me into jeffrey's room to be raped
and then when i walked out
well walked limped i mean whatever you
do when you've just been been brutally
raped
i looked at her
and that's why it was really important
for me to be there
and look at her because when i looked at
her
after she forced me into that room to be
raped
she smiled
and that's why i had to be there because
you know what
i smiled right back right back at her
when i saw her
four survivors took the stand in this
case they were girls when they were
abused they're now grown women who
stepped out of the shadows and into this
court to tell their story and ultimately
it was that testimony which brought down
gulen maxwell
but after the verdict her family and
friends remained defiant
we firmly believe in glenn's innocence
obviously we are very disappointed with
the verdict we have already started
working on the appeal and we are
confident that she will be vindicated
your excellencies presidents laws ladies
and gentlemen maxwell once used her
platform to address the un she traveled
the world in a way only the super
wealthy ever will but her privilege in
the end was no protection for the crimes
she committed martha kellner sky news
new york
and martha has the latest from new york
there was a huge amount of tension in
the court i think mainly because this
verdict had taken much longer than many
expected to be returned judge allison
nathan
got out her yellow note and said we have
a verdict at that point there was an
audible intake of breath from everyone
in that courtroom and in the overflow
courtrooms to to watch this hearing this
deliberation period take place
guillen maxwell sat relatively
motionless rather devoid of emotion as
the charges against her and the verdicts
were read out she was found guilty of
five of the six charges against her as
that final charge was read out count six
the most serious count on the charge
sheet she was found guilty of sex
trafficking which carries a maximum
40-year sentence in prison she simply
looked down at the table in front of her
the defense table in front of her she
took a sip of water
from her paper cup she then stood up
there was a very brief pat on the back
from one of her defense lawyers jeffrey
palayuka there was then the briefest of
glances behind her to her family who was
sat
on the front row of that courtroom her
sister's isabella isabel apologies and
christine and her brother kevin
she gave them a brief glance before
u.s marshals led her out of that
courtroom
afterwards her lawyer bobby sternheim as
you saw there in my report and spoke out
and said her family will appeal they are
very much um defiant in disbelief at
this verdict
martha kellner there in new york for us
now the nhs is setting up new
nightingale surge hubs across england to
deal with a potential wave of omicron
hospital admissions work on eight sites
each with a capacity of around 100
patients is set to begin as early as
this week as the nhs prepares to go on a
war footing against the virus sky sergey
chowdhury reports
last year's new year's resolution to
help the national vaccine
programme so that is you i've done it
thank you
let's do it nearly a thousand hours
later and nobody in the east of england
has volunteered more hours than alex
pence
it's all about them getting to do things
when they're freed up from this so we
had a lady the other day where she said
i'd literally saved her wedding because
she needed a vaccination within the next
two days or she wasn't going to be able
to get to barbados for the wedding it's
not just wedding days being saved
volunteer contribution is also helping
keep pressure off and nhs under strain
despite record-breaking vaccination
figures this past fortnight omicron
remains on the rise and the nhs is
taking no chances
this is a new temporary nightingale hub
being built
one of an initial eight sites across
england
in london the hub will be here at st
george's hospital nhs trusts have been
asked to help identify more sites like
gyms and education centers that can be
converted to help create up to 4 000
so-called super surge beds the expansion
comes as the number of people in
hospitals with kovid rose above 10 000
for the first time since march
what we're doing here is we're preparing
for the worst whilst hoping for the best
it's it's a no regrets approach what you
don't want to do is hit a point where
you need to treat very large numbers of
patients but you simply don't have the
facilities and capacity to do it
questions remain over who will staff the
new hubs the royal college of nursing
has sounded the alarm over worker
shortages and low morale
a survey of more than 9 000 uk nursing
staff has found that 57 said they're
considering or planning on leaving their
job
around three quarters said that in the
last year they'd worked when feeling
unwell
and 18 said they weren't able to take
annual leave
we've got a nursing profession that's
under intolerable
pressures
it's a workforce and crisis and if we
don't address the crisis in the nursing
profession then we won't have a health
and care service that's fit to deliver
for those that are in desperate need of
it and deserve actually the care and
that the health service should be able
to deliver the nightingale surge hubs
become the latest response to the rapid
spread of omicron and the prospect of
another major wave of people relying on
the nhs for treatment
sadia chowdhury sky news
we're staying with kovid 19 and an extra
8 million home testing kits are to be
made available before the new year after
shortages caused by exceptionally high
demand the uk health security agency has
warned that increased demand could
continue to lead to a shortage in
lateral flow and pcr tests both of which
were unavailable for home delivery
across the uk via the government website
on wednesday professor alex richter a
clinical immunologist at the university
of birmingham says difficulty accessing
pcr tests is forcing her family into
isolation after her daughter returned to
positive lateral flow results
i look after individuals with vulnerable
immune systems and so at high risk
so i wouldn't be able to go back to work
without a pcr test i probably wouldn't
go back and see patients face to face
anyway because of how vulnerable my
patient cohort is
but it doesn't allow any of us to
release and we would have to remain in
an isolated manner for the next 10 days
let's bring in our political
correspondent joe pike who's at
westminster forest morning joe so why
are we experiencing this lack of tests
simply it's because we have seen a huge
uptick in the number of cases that of
course is going to lead to people
wanting to test to see whether they have
a cover 19 or not but also partly
because the self-isolation rules have
changed last week the uk government
reduced the amount of time you need to
self-isolate if you test positive from
10 days to 7 as long as you have a
lateral flow test and test negative on
day six and seven that is likely to
increase demand as is the guidance from
the government that if you've come into
close contact with someone who's
positive you don't need to self-isolate
but ideally you take lateral flow tests
every day for a week and the shortage of
tests is certainly continuing this
morning on the uk government's website
there are no home tests for the general
public or for essential workers in the
nhs and care staff and in terms of the
walk in and drive through a testing
centers those are not available in
scotland northern ireland and eight out
of nine english regions this challenge
is continuing the government are saying
they're expanding capacity and the
people should check their website every
few hours what we are though perhaps
seeing jonathan is a change in the way
people are behaving acting more
responsibly in testing regularly that is
becoming part of everyday life but it is
only possible for us to do that if we
can get the test from government and uh
for now it's quite difficult
all right joe thank you
well we can get some more now on those
pressures being felt by nurses and the
warning from the royal college of
nursing that there's a growing sense of
disillusionment amongst staff joining me
now is the royal college of nursing's
general secretary pat cullen you saw her
in that report a little bit earlier very
good morning to you thanks for being
with us we'll talk about all the
pressures that nursing staff are under
in a moment but first of all just give
me your reaction to these uh covered
hubs that are being set up a sensible
idea or not so easy to do
well
i don't know about uh how easy they are
to do because you can set up all the
hubs and that you wish to set up but if
you don't have the nursing staff to
actually
care for the patients that are going to
be placed in those hubs that places more
challenges on the nursing workforce the
nursing workforce already are struggling
and massively to care for the patients
that are already in hospital and we set
up hubs and put on and put up additional
beds that's going to even place more
pressure on those nurses so at this
point in time we have no idea how we're
going to be um staffing those additional
hubs as they're set up
it appears that these hubs are going to
be largely for patients who are getting
better and are close to being discharged
from hospital um could you argue that
actually this will make life easier for
those nursing staff inside the main
building who are trying to look after
the critically ill
well where you see a bed in a hospital
you inevitably see nurses so those beds
will still have to be staffed by nurses
the patients in those beds will still
require nursing care
and so the nurses that are already
providing the critical care and
hospitals will even be spread thinner
across those areas unless there's
another plan to staff those beds and
care for those patients in another way
but at this point in time that
information isn't available so we are
working on the premise that if there's a
bed put up in a hospital or in a
makeshift hospital inevitably that bed
requires a nurse to be present provide
the care for patients
uh we're heading into uh another year
it'll be our third year with uh kovid
hanging over us uh what does that mean
for
those in your profession
well we can see in this report today the
stark statistics in the report that has
been um issued today
but it's not just the statistics behind
each and every one of the statistics in
that report and there's a story to be
told and we can see those stories in
the report and that's been published
today
and personally and professionally each
and every nurse has paid a massive price
um over the last number of years they
headed into this pandemic
with 50 000 nursing vacancies in the nhs
in england and then on top of that we
now have a situation where thousands of
nurses are off isolating so you can
imagine what it's like for those nurses
that are still um getting up as we speak
this morning to start a 13 14 hour shift
and care for patients with a depleted
workforce and knowing that there's no
way into it that it's just relentless
and the words that they just they they
say to me on a daily basis is that it
has become intolerable and
you know throughout my 37 year
nursing career i never thought that i
would see a report issue today that
shows 57
of our workforce wishing to leave the
profession that certainly was never
something that i thought i would see in
my time
and of course you know
we're all hugely grateful to the work
that nurses do but we are in
unprecedented times aren't we kovit
has taken its toll on so many people in
so many different uh walks of life um is
it fair to completely blame the
government for the situation that
nursing staff find themselves in well
the nursing workforce has been subject
to cost cutting exercises year on year
by success of governments and there has
been an absolute total absence and lack
of workforce planning and cuts made to
nursing permanent posts filled with
temporary vacancies in order to get
money out of the service those are not
issues that have been created by the
nursing workforce indeed the nursing
workforce has stepped up and stepped out
for the public and patients time and
time again so someone has to take
responsibility but what we're seeing is
moving forward there needs to be
accountability and responsibility for
long-term workforce planning there needs
to be investment in the service and we
need a workforce that is fit for purpose
that can deliver for the public and take
the pressure off the front line those
nurses that are trying every day to do
their very best for patients so that
they can go home after their shift and
know that there's not care left undone
that they don't feel that their patients
are being subjected to unsafe care when
we have got a workforce that is
absolutely highly valued by the public
that are skilled and expert in providing
that care and it's it's down to the
government unfortunately i do have to
say that it is down to the government to
make sure that the patients and the
public have got the workforce to provide
that care for them
okay uh we must leave it there pat
cullen general secretary of the royal
college of nursing thank you thank you
okay let's take a look at some of the
other stories making news this morning
the u.s has called on china to
immediately release employees of the
pro-democracy media outlet stand news
after they were arrested by hong kong
authorities the uk government also
joined the u.s in condemning the actions
calling the arrests a curtailing of
media freedoms but hong kong leader
carrie lam claimed the arrests were a
law enforcement action and were not
aimed at the media industry
the foreign secretary liz truss has
pledged up to 105 million pounds of uk
emergency aid to help vulnerable
countries tackle the omicron covet 19
variant the foreign office says the aid
will help countries most in need fight
kovit 19 with a particular focus on
africa it's hoped the funding will help
millions of people by supporting
measures to reduce transmission scale up
testing and boost oxygen supplies
well that announcement comes exactly one
year after the uk became the first
country to approve the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine two and a half
billion doses of that job have since
been administered around the world
including 50 million here in the uk
health secretary sajid javid says the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine has been
absolutely pivotal in saving millions of
lives globally
now a maintenance worker has suffered
serious injuries after being attacked by
a tiger when he entered an unauthorized
area of a florida zoo authorities at the
naples zoo shot and killed the tiger to
free the man from its jaws
almost 100 convicted terrorists are
being assessed for release from prison
by the parole board with several cases
being decided in the next few months
skies emma virtually is in the newsroom
for us now morning emma so give us some
more detail well we're actually talking
about 92 convicted terrorists it would
have been in the past that they would
have been automatically released at the
halfway point in their sentence but
emergency laws were brought in in
february of 2020 following two terror
attacks committed by
recently released terrorist prisoners
attacks at fishmongers hall and
streatham two within three months both
in london and so now these convicted
terrorists have to serve at least
two-thirds of their sentence and then
they have to appear before a parole
panel who have to decide if they're safe
before their release so the kind of
people we're talking about are jawad
akbar for example he plotted to bomb the
blue water shopping center in kent in
the ministry of sound nightclub in
london back in 2004. jack coulson a
teenager who made a pipe bomb in his
bedroom which is was covered with nazi
flags so you can see why people would be
concerned about the prospect of these
kind of people re-entering society now
the parole board say that public safety
is the top priority and that actually
these parole board panels that make
these decisions are really being beefed
up with more specialists the kind of
people judges senior police officers
prisoner prison governors psychologists
psychiatrists so they are the people who
are making these decisions the problem
according to nick aldworth who is a
former national counter-terrorism
coordinator
is that these people are clever and they
can cheat the system
the trouble with ideologically based um
offending
is it is quite easy to conceal your your
deep views
but of course
those are also views that come and go
and you know there will be a case coming
up um this year where an individual had
not been on the police radar for several
years
and then committed an appalling act
these are not easy decisions to make
about the future of these convicted
terrorists so to give you an example
since the new legislation came in 22
months ago
117 cases have been referred to the
parole board of those only 11 people
have been released and 14 have been
refused release
welcome back you're watching sky news
breakfast now the 60 year old british
socialite giles maxwell is facing the
rest of her life behind bars after being
found guilty of recruiting underage
girls to be sexually abused by geoffrey
epstein maxwell who is described as
epstein's partner in crime by the
prosecution during her three-week trial
was convicted on five of the six counts
that she was charged with our u.s
correspondent greg milan takes a look at
the background of the case and verdict
during elaine maxwell's trial a teenage
accuser was asked why she didn't speak
out or fight back
because she said she knew she was
isolated here in a mansion owned by
jeffrey epstein on an 8 000 acre ranch
in the middle of the desert isolated she
said
with just those two people
the photos of that palatial home in new
mexico now come marked with evidence
labels the property revealed in the
trial as being central to the sex
trafficking operation of epstein and
maxwell's role
laid bare by those brought here their
experience of what went on beyond the
gate of zorro ranch
and this is just one property in a
global portfolio in which jeffrey
epstein and elaine maxwell could operate
exclusive homes in new york and florida
and the virgin islands where as you can
see they could stay well away from the
public gaze and as the trial heard the
means to travel between them that also
kept them in their own private world
because behind the gates and the
security cameras zorro ranch has its own
airstrip freedom of movement for epstein
and maxwell and their guests here the
flight logs of epstein's private jets
revealed in the trial the world of the
rich famous and powerful in which they
moved
with maxwell at its heart a who's who of
politicians power brokers and performers
none of those named in court were
accused of any wrongdoing but they
demonstrated a couple with unrivaled
connections
the lawyer for some of epstein's
accusers ones whose allegations weren't
heard during the trial say it was
maxwell's presence that won the trust of
those who became victims
mr epstein would have never been able to
abuse the number of women that he did
had it not been for the part that galen
maxwell played
in that sexual
pyramid the wealth
and influence that jeffrey epstein and
glenn maxwell had throughout the world
allowed them to continue on this path
for as long as they did
the problems associated with their
wealth and and influence
is that they were always given the
benefit of the doubt in situations where
questions should have clearly been
raised
all the many
hundreds of people
who have sent
messages of support those who know galen
maxwell point to her past and the death
of her father the disgraced tycoon
robert maxwell on his yacht 30 years ago
she was very upset
she was crying about her daddy she was
obviously you know a daddy's girl
the youngest
ken lennox identified robert maxwell's
body after his death the death of
epstein he believes drove prosecutors to
go after gelane maxwell they lost
jeffrey and
she was the next
there's no one else visible
to punish for what happened to these
girls i think she was under the
influence
of a man who in many ways
resembled her father
towards the end of gelaine maxwell's
trial the jury was shown this video from
inside the home in palm beach in florida
where prosecutors say she and jeffrey
epstein committed horrifying crimes
their exclusive world is now no more
that house has been demolished for many
the memories can never be erased greg
milam sky news
well back here the british dental
association says the government's
decision to impose new activity targets
is the wrong choice at the wrong time
from the 1st of january nhs dentists in
england will have to meet 85 of their
pre-covered levels or face financial
penalties joining me now is the chair of
the british dental association eddie
crouch very good morning to you thanks
sir for joining us here on sky news
breakfast that meeting 85 of your
pre-covered uh appointments doesn't
sound uh too tough why is it a problem
well it's a massive problem at the
moment we've had yesterday 185 000
people
testing positive
many of the teams the dental teams are
struggling working flat out
and two-thirds of those
teams have not managed to achieve that
target previously and we're going into
deeper
numbers within the pandemic we're having
problems with staffing many of our staff
are off with with symptoms or having to
self-isolate
many of our patients are
uh the contract itself is not very um
uh
satisfactory and setting a target like
this is setting dentists up to fail
so what exactly how have the government
said that 85 percent of pre-covered
levels what else have you got to achieve
well that in itself is is is a real
shock to the profession um because as i
say only two-thirds well sorry only a
third of practices previously were
hitting that target
sorry why is that
uh well
we've been working to incredible uh
cross infection control procedures since
the pandemic started
we've had the situation where we've had
to have uh downtime after each
particular patient
trying to see 85 percent of the numbers
of patients that we saw uh pre-pandemic
is just not possible
is there not an argument though that uh
some of those measures can be relaxed
now we already know that dental
practices are some of the cleanest
places that you can go to you've been
wearing ppe uh well before we even knew
what ppe stood for social distancing for
example i know some dentists say that
you have to have social distancing in in
the waiting rooms well no one else is
doing social distancing why do you need
to
because we're seeing patients that are
potentially vulnerable within our
surgeries and
no other area of the health service is
actually being put under this pressure
my colleagues feel they're not being
supported properly like other areas of
the health service we understand there
is a massive backlog 35 million
appointments have been lost um we've got
the situation where um many patients
healthwatch for example are reporting
that is one of the major issues
that they're getting reported within the
health service we need support not
targets that are put there that are
setting dentists up to fail many many
practices are wondering about their
long-term future in the nhs because they
don't see the support coming from the
nhs at this particular time
you say that you're facing
more pressures than other areas of the
nhs but how can you possibly believe
that we've just been speaking to the the
royal college of nursing
saying that they're under
huge stress and pressure at the moment i
mean nobody saw kovid coming and we have
to deal with it is it not time for you
to think about your own working
practices and how you can change them to
improve so that these targets can be at
least got close to
well i think dental practices have
adapted absolutely fantastically to the
problems of the pandemic but other areas
of the health service have been
receiving funding for example additional
support
and and dentistry has not got that in
the
uh spending review that was done
recently uh and the 5 billion pound that
was there to actually deal with backlogs
in the nhs not a single penny of that
has come to dentistry and it's not all
about the money but dentists feel like
they're not being supported at this
particular time
and we are working in vulnerable
situations close up to patients
dealing with aerosol generating
procedures yes we have all the
procedures in place but that takes time
and that doesn't allow us to see the
volume of patients that the nhs are
expecting us to see
okay uh you make your point uh very well
we appreciate your time this morning
eddie crouch chair of the british dental
association thank you
okay let's see how your thursday weather
is shaping up
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well it's been so mild hasn't it of late
you may not even need a coat today
because it's going to remain mild today
but it will turn colder before the new
year especially on sunday it's rather
great for most with rain across central
britain heavy showers for northern
scotland dry elsewhere central britain
will largely dry up during the morning
although it'll stay gray and drizzly on
western hills but the south can expect
further patchy rain the south of ireland
will see heavier more prolonged
outbreaks moving in elsewhere showers
over northern scotland will clear
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well thanks for your company this
morning do stay with us coming up we're
going to take a look through the
morning's papers with broadcasters and
journalists after adam and thomas
copeland don't go away
[Music]
did you know if we tried to use less
energy we could help reduce air
pollution
what like turning off the lights and
stuff yeah
central britain will see early rain
mostly dying out during the morning
although it'll stay rather gray and
drizzly on western hills but the south
will see further patchy outbreaks the
south of ireland can expect heavier more
prolonged rain by midday elsewhere
northern scotland will see early showers
clearing leaving most northern and
central parts fine it'll stay very mild
rain in the south will clear into
central parts during the afternoon
southwesterly winds mean air pollution
levels will remain low with most places
between 1 and three on the air quality
index
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello again it's 7 47 if you're just
joining us a very good morning time to
look through the papers today i'm joined
by journalists adam and thomas copeland
nice to see you both uh again why don't
we kick off uh with you this time thomas
front page of the mirror a story that
broke late last night our top story of
course
and the mirror uh their headlines simply
guilty the conviction of galaine maxwell
and when you read the detail it really
is very depressing indeed
yeah i mean it's a very disturbing story
through and through watching the sky
news reports this morning though i mean
what strikes you is how long maxwell was
able to get away
with what she did the bbc have a comment
on their website from their new york
correspondent actually this morning that
struck me
comments about how the first time that
this correspondent had come across
maxwell was a decade ago chasing her
down a street in manhattan asking her
about exactly these kind of allegations
so for for at least 10 years this is a
pr this has been you know something that
at least journalists were aware of and
considerably longer than that for the
victims uh epstein died in 2019 so he'll
never be able to fully answer to his
alleged crimes but it would appear that
maxwell was very much a linchpin for all
of those but of course you know there's
no dignity in crime and much of
maxwell's defense relied upon turning on
her once partner in crime accusing um
epstein of of using her as a scapegoat
and how uh he was very much in control
of all of this but of course watching
most of the covers it's fairly clear
that maxwell was fundamental um to
fundamentals of these crimes taking
place epstein couldn't have done it by
himself as the allegation being made so
you get the distinct impression though
from all of this that
this is really only scratching the
surface about uh you know for 10 years
for for far longer than 10 years between
holidays and holiday homes and and
travel and houses across the world you
have sort of a network underneath which
um
underneath which these kind of crimes
were taking place yeah you hope that
this is the beginning of a process not
only for you know the actual victims but
also a much wider process for society in
general uncovering some of the
criminality that's that's taken place
clearly hidden beneath that web of power
wealth and influence yeah you make a
very good point there after uh
the ramifications of this case will
continue weren't they
oh absolutely and like thomas said
earlier on and i think this was probably
going to maybe open the floodgates for
other people who were victims of jeffrey
epstein angeline maxwell to come forward
and talk about what they went through
and i think that will be a good thing so
they can be fully held accountable for
the crimes they committed against so
many young people but i also think this
reminds me when we talk about these kind
of cases money wealth and power and what
they can do to hide your crimes it
reminds me of the r kelly case again
journalists knew for years of the crimes
that he committed like journalists knew
for years of the crimes that glenn
maxwell and jeffrey epstein committed
but they were able to cover them up like
i said for years so i think this is far
from over that more people will come
forward but i also think it will
encourage people who are perhaps victims
of other people
we don't know who they may be but who
have gone through something similar to
come forward and say look you know i
went through this even if it is against
a person who has money in power i think
this is going to egg people on and and
say that you know what you can get
justice justice if that's what you
deserve so i think we could see more of
these cases coming forward as well but i
think elaine maxwell probably going to
prison for the rest of her life will
definitely give her victims some sense
of closure i also think this could put
the spotlight on prince andrew of course
he has denied all the allegations
against him but u.s authorities are
still looking to speak to him
right okay uh we're we seem to be losing
your signal again after it's not a good
morning uh for your broadband uh thomas
let's uh move on to uh testing and and
the latest issues there because it's
still a real problem isn't it people
struggling to get lateral flow tests and
pcr tests the guardians saying that the
prime minister is to blame for the
testing shambles
this has been a major problem for huge
numbers of people up and down the
country i've been only in the last
couple of days i've been checking the
website trying to order some some
lateral flow tests and you find that in
many cases are simply unavailable i know
that there are even more acute problems
in england for example than there are in
scotland wales and northern ireland and
the pcr test is a very important part of
that the way that the process is meant
to work is you take a lateral flow test
if you get a positive lateral flow test
you send off for a pcr test so once you
start to get not only a problem with
lateral flow tests coming through the
door but also then pcr test due to an
increased demand you very quickly walk
into a system that seems to be falling
apart now i suppose the the reason that
that the fingers being pointed by the at
the prime minister in this article and
elsewhere is for example him encouraging
people to go out and actually the
government's saying have a good time on
new year's eve
but increasingly saying that testing is
the key so in the past we've talked
about how you know vaccines are the way
out of this noise there seems to be a
little bit a move towards saying you
know what's about testing is really
important at this current phase of the
pandemic but the problem with doing that
of course is you need to make sure that
before you tell people get testing get
the lateral flow test get the pcr test
you have enough capacity in order to
allow people to do that when you've got
people trying to get home for christmas
maybe see some of their family you've
got folks going out on new year's eve
you've also got and this is one of the
sort of a zeitgeisty thing isn't it when
when you hear of one person getting a
test or your family is getting attached
you're more likely to do it yourself
you're more likely to order more we
should be encouraging people to get more
tests and to do a quick test before they
go out somewhere but there's no point in
doing that if it's going to take 48
hours for people to you know for far
longer than that or people will never be
able to get tests and what that actually
will lead to is more people inclined to
break the rules for example if you want
to visit maybe a family member in a
nursing home or a hospital and you're
encouraged to take a lateral flow test
before you go there if you aren't able
to get one then clearly it is the case
that you know your desperation maybe to
see a family member will overcome those
initial thoughts to do with
that yeah you make a very good point
there and that that is a real problem uh
the government's saying that eight
million tests are going to be put into
the system uh very soon we shall wait
and see um staying with kovid um we've
got afford back uh now um afwa the
financial times uh talking about the um
tsunami of covid around the world um
it is a real issue isn't it while casey
is obviously going up here in the uk and
the u.s as well more record levels of
kovi cases but
elsewhere in the world really the
problems are only just beginning
oh yes absolutely and this is the
director general of the wh holy doctor
tedros cabrerases and he has warned of
this tsunami as you put it of covert um
around the world we've had record cases
in the us 265
000 daily in france 208 000 in germany
13 000 omnicorn cases um and here's
warning of a surge of omicron and delta
all over the world india is reporting a
surge in cases as well and he says you
know even though omicron is being
reported as being mulder that we
shouldn't be complacent the cases are
going to put um pressure on health care
workers and healthcare systems around
the world but he also commented on
booster vaccines which i thought was
really interesting and he said that
there has been more booster vaccines
given out in richer countries than there
has been the total number of vaccines
that's first and second doses that have
gone out in lower and middle income
countries
and that
explanation
oh i thought we need to get we need to
give your broadband a booster uh that's
what we're going to have to try and sort
out for the next hour uh thomas we
talked about dinosaurs earlier just give
me 20 seconds on the tequila fish
well it's the headline of the day the
guardian is reporting at the times is
reporting another shot they said for the
tequila fish well hey wake up favorite
headline of the day it's a fish that
chester zoo actually in the uk has
helped to rehabilitate it was declared
extinct from the wild in 2003 as being
reintroduced you can see a picture of it
there lovely little thing back into the
wild so a little bit of good news story
uh
and a wonderful headline thomas we're
out time thanks very much